With the Summer Olympic Games
only six weeks away,
Brazil is worried because more
than two million tickets
remain unsold
and many are blaming fears
about the Zika virus.
Uh, Irish golfer Rory McIlroy
is the latest athlete
to say he'll be skipping
the Games.
Now, yes, it's true there appear
to be a number of reasons
to be nervous
about visiting Brazil.
Like because
an Australian Paralympian
was mugged at gunpoint
this week,
or because half of Rio
de Janeiro's sewage is dumped
-into open waterways...
-(audience exclaims)
...or maybe 'cause Reuters
recently reported
on a drug-resistant
super-bacteria
on the triathlon beach,
or maybe the fact
their president is currently
being overthrown in an angry
political uprising...
-(laughter)
-or possibly because
the official national bird
is a Molotov cocktail,
-or...
-(laughter)
...possibly because the Olympic
mascot, an Amazonian jaguar,
escaped and had to be shot
by the army
-before it attacked people.
-(audience groans)
Not to mention, sometimes
there's piranhas,
uh, also malaria
and the fact that, perhaps,
the country may have invented
the killer bees.
But it's gonna be fine.
It's all gonna be fine.
Don't worry.
After all, Brazil...
Listen, guys,
Brazil gave us Pelé
-and pussy waxing and...
-(laughter, whooping)
and-and-and antivenin.
-Antivenin.
-(whooping)
(Hardwick laughs)
The guy with the snake looks way
more excited to be doing this
than she does to be doing that.
We're trying
to stay positive here.
We're very positive,
Brazil's a wonderful place,
is a beautiful nation,
plenty to offer the world.
Please give me some other great
reasons to go to Brazil.
Burnie Burns.
At least you don't have
to smuggle in
your own performance-enhancing
drugs.
HARDWICK:
Yeah. Perfect.
It's already... already there.
It's a positive.
Gavin.
Brazil is actually
ranked higher
than most countries
alphabetically.
(laughter, applause)
Absolutely.
Barbara.
Uh, you can get a selfie
with a homeless guy
masturbating on the street.
Yeah, perfect. Perfect.
So, go to Brazil
and celebrate the Olympics.